okay so you decide to leave school yeah
at that point in time you stay in North
Carolina you go back home what are you
doing
um I just was going back and forth I was
still kind of like working and then I
got a job at a club and it was just like
I was running it up making money from
there and uh what were you doing at the
club I was dancing you were stripping
okay so
um shout out to all the ladies out to
get their money yes get that bread get
that bag my wife used to be a dancer so
no judgment here I mean listen listen I
know more strippers making more money
than drug dealers to this deck and
a lot riskier less risky yeah even
though yo there's something about strip
club politics that because I used to DJ
a lot at strip clubs so I've been in the
locker rooms I've seen [ __ ] beat the
[ __ ] out of each other oh yeah over like
whose bucket got Fuller from someone
making it rain like the strip club
politics are crazy I ended up getting
fired that's how I ended up stopping
because it was like so it was just I
hated my job but it was like the money
was so good that I was like I was trying
to figure out how I could walk away from
it for good because you know you will
stop a little bit here a little bit
right right yeah like I need some money
let me go work for a weekend yeah or
just you know you get a [ __ ] you you
know yeah you just be like okay well I'm
gonna start a business that don't work
out you already know you're going back
to strip club why why'd you get fired
I Spit on a girl you spit on her yeah I
mean at least she didn't assault her I
mean you kind of did but yeah I really
shouldn't beat her up no I couldn't it
was like security
yeah like that was the only way like I
could kind of get to it was it over like
some money yeah of course because that's
the only reason why I'm here like I
don't give a [ __ ] about you [ __ ] I'm
here you know why I'm here yeah what
city was this this is in Charlotte
Charlotte yeah hey CIAA weekends are
probably lit as [ __ ] oh man it was going
crazy I mean we was on like they would
make like the news like for people
spending like hundreds of thousand
dollars a a night on the weekends that's
crazy what was the most amount of money
in your short-lived dancing career that
you made in one night
um
like a little over 20k Jesus Christ yeah
I would never quit
but every night it don't be like that
but tell you something I have my ass out
until they would tell me I had to leave
but you know now you explains why I
didn't want to leave it was like you
know no I get it it's also like mentally
taxing I don't think people understand
like your job is to
like make like like
it's it I can only imagine my wife's
explain it to me like it is mentally
taxing to like hit reset and then try to
like you have to kind of be everybody's
fantasy slash counselor slash person
they trust like even if it's for 20
minutes like and you do that however
long right and like it's like [ __ ] it
was a long night you know like yeah and
no black clubs is a little bit different
because like you know you got to deal
with all the street [ __ ] that'd be
coming into the club yeah so the club I
used to DJ at in Phoenix called Jaguars
legendary strip club
um it's very much the epicenter of
all of the street [ __ ] in Phoenix
everybody comes there at 2 A.M after the
regular Club gets out and everybody
who's got beef with everybody is all in
the same [ __ ] place every single
[ __ ] night it's it's like you could
sometimes you could feel the [ __ ]
tension in there yeah it's like oh [ __ ]
and imagine it's like you ain't got no
choice you gotta get this [ __ ]
bag like you praying that [ __ ] don't
be shooting or you know what I'm saying
like ah for sure it's crazy it's wild
yeah fights happen like you said people
right yeah I don't care about the fights
it'd be the shooting part for me yeah
yeah I can imagine